Alice:阿姨这个瓶也不要了
Alice: Auntie, we don't need this bottle either.
阿姨：楼上有人吗
Auntie: Is anyone upstairs?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:阿姨这个桌子能擦吗
Alice: Auntie, can we wipe this table?
Alice:这个桌子能擦吗
Alice: Can we wipe this table?
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
阿姨：你们这个布是不是擦桌子用啊
Auntie: Is this cloth for wiping the table?
Alice:嗯可以用
Alice: Yeah, it can be used.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:对这个不要了
Alice: Yeah, we don't need this either.
阿姨：这个还要吗
Auntie: Do you still need this?
Alice:这个不要了
Alice: We don't need this.
Alice:嗯好的
Alice: Yeah, okay.
Alice:阿姨这个也不要了
Alice: Auntie, we don't need this either.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
阿姨：还有吗
Auntie: Is there anything else?
Alice:嗯没了
Alice: No, that's it.
Alice:哦这几个瓶子也不要
Alice: Oh, we don't need these bottles either.
阿姨：那是整的
Auntie: That's all intact.
阿姨：那个空的我给扔了
Auntie: I'll throw away the empty one.
Alice:这个
Alice: This one.
Alice:呃
Alice: Uh.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh.
Alice:笨蛋
Alice: Idiot.
Alice:就这一点喝了得了
Alice: Just drink this little bit.
Jack: 他自己他
Jack: He himself, he...
Shure: 家里变干净了一些
Shure: The house is a bit cleaner.
Alice:一些
Alice: A bit.
Alice:这不是很多吗
Alice: Isn't this a lot?
Jack: 要么就都是
Jack: Either all of it is.
Jack: 要么就都不是
Jack: Or none of it is.
Nicous: 关键就是你
Nicous: The key thing is you.
Nicous: 就是就是
Nicous: Exactly, exactly.
Nicous: 如果你训
Nicous: If you train...
Nicous: 但如果你训QA的话
Nicous: But if you train QA.
Nicous: 就是你训
Nicous: If you train...
Nicous: 你训QA的话
Nicous: If you train QA.
Nicous: 其实需要意味着分辨率比较高
Nicous: It actually means the resolution is quite high.
Nicous: 但是如果你做公众号那种
Nicous: But if you do something like a public account.
Nicous: 因为你interneb的话
Nicous: Because if you use the internet.
Nicous: 其实意味着分辨率不重要
Nicous: It actually means resolution is not important.
Nicous: 就你要有
Nicous: As long as you have...
Katrina: 真的吗我我同学他们就也就是那种
Katrina: Really? My classmates are just like that too.
Choiszt: 但你图也没啥意义
Choiszt: But your pictures are meaningless.
Choiszt: 就是有很多图都没什么意义
Choiszt: Like, a lot of pictures are meaningless.
Nicous: 只要只要只要有一些那种
Nicous: As long as there are some like that.
Katrina: 你要升博
Katrina: You want to get a PhD.
Alice:就拍拍照片
Alice: Just take pictures.
Katrina: 这个漏应该
Katrina: This leak should...
Nicous: 但是就是差距太大了
Nicous: But the gap is too big.
Nicous: 研究生特别好吃
Nicous: Graduate students eat really well.
Choiszt: 所以你们那种数据
Choiszt: So your kind of data...
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina: 对啊我喜欢吃他们那种
Katrina: Yeah, I like eating their kind of food.
Nicous: 就是就是
Nicous: Exactly, exactly.
Nicous: 理论上来说
Nicous: In theory...
Jack: 他也没训出来啊
Jack: He didn't train it out either.
Choiszt: 所以你们关键公众号也发达
Choiszt: So your key public account is also developed.
Alice:有没有觉得非常干净
Alice: Doesn't it feel really clean?
Choiszt: 那你怎么配对
Choiszt: Then how do you match?
Katrina: 但是你们去除了港大
Katrina: But you guys excluded HKU.
Lucia:谢谢可心好干净
Lucia: Thanks, Kexin, it's so clean.
Alice:但是一摆又又又凌乱了
Alice: But once you put it down, it's messy again.
Alice:有没有觉得这个家有什么区别
Alice: Do you feel any difference in this home?
Jake:您嗑瓜子请呵呵
Jake: Please have some sunflower seeds.
Lucia:特别有区别
Lucia: There's a big difference.
Alice:不用了谢谢
Alice: No, thank you.
Lucia:请请请您吃
Lucia: Please, have some.
Alice:请请请您吃这个
Alice: Please, have this.
Lucia:这个已经打开了哦那
Lucia: This is already opened, so...
Alice:我不吃巧克力
Alice: I don't eat chocolate.
Lucia:喝喝喝来来来杯茶
Lucia: Drink, drink, have a cup of tea.
Alice:谢谢哈哈哈哈
Alice: Thank you, hahaha.
Jack: 因为一整个公众号的信息就是
Jack: Because the entire WeChat official account's information is...
Alice:现在只有就剩刷的东西没有弄了
Alice: Now there's only the scrubbing left to do.
Jake:好我们来刷
Jake: Okay, let's scrub.
Alice:还有楼上的桌子什么也擦了
Alice: And upstairs, the tables need wiping too.
Alice:然后也只剩刷了
Alice: And then there's only scrubbing left.
Jake:我们开摄像头
Jake: Let's turn on the cameras.
Jack: 开摄像头啊
Jack: Turn on the cameras?
Jake:大家先休息一下
Jake: Everyone take a break first.
Jake:不要工作
Jake: No work.
其他人：这个去哪了啊啊
Others: Where did this go? Ahh...
Jake:这个不要了
Jake: We don't need this.
Tasha:那这个眼镜就关掉了啊
Tasha: Then I'll turn off these glasses, okay?
Jake:呃关关关
Jake: Uh, turn them off, turn them off.
Jake:倒一批
Jake: Dump a batch.
Nicous: 然后如果是QA的话
Nicous: And if it's QA...
Nicous: 最高每天能去22K
Nicous: The highest can reach 22K per day.
Choiszt: 2048*2048
Choiszt: 2048*2048.
Nicous: 呃 1920乘多少我忘记了
Nicous: Uh, 1920 by something, I forgot.
Nicous: 我去拿2K
Nicous: I'll get the 2K.